All right, thanks for joining us again for another Zoom call everybody and of course this recording will be up on our new platform which everyone will have the opportunity to be in and access those recordings that will that is going to be called our membership site so all of our patients will be members and they'll be have access to the membership site.
Good news is we're launching it tomorrow morning so tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock central you should all get an email and you'll have to create a user name and a password actually your user name is your email.
And then you'll just create a password and you'll have access to the site and on that site is where you'll ask the questions for the Zoom calls so if you have questions for Zoom calls you'll submit it on the form on that site.
And also you'll have access to all the other Zoom call recordings so you will no longer have to ask your liaison or myself for those recording links they'll all be on that site so much other information and a lot of frequently asked questions and then what we'll be doing is when you guys ask certain questions and you submit them sometimes I'll make some short videos of those questions because I think they're really good questions that are frequently asked.
And then there will be up on that site for everybody to see in a short video format so they don't have to listen to this whole blast and Zoom call to get their questions answered, which will be very nice.
Reminder again to everybody who's new everybody hears me say this all the time but if you do have a question that you're looking for an answer do first go to our blog post and search or just search on our any place on the website.
That little little deal about thing right there and ask your question and that we may have made a blog post about it or a video about it already so then you don't have to wait for the Zoom call or wait for somebody to answer my question.
Question about H. Pylori and stomach cancer so for those who don't have stomach cancer H. Pylori is a major cause of stomach cancer but H. Pylori is a major cause of a lot of things not just stomach cancer.
H. Pylori is helical back to Pylori it's a bacteria that's common it's not common it's ubiquitous.
As a matter of fact everybody has some most people I should say have some form of H. Pylori some species of H. Pylori that is a part of their microbiota.
But it's when H. Pylori gets out of hand it starts growing when it starts growing and grows in the stomach it is the cause of stomach ulcers but it is also the most kind of cause of stomach cancer worldwide but it also causes other things it is top five causes of cardiovascular endothelial dysfunction.
It's a major cause of other cancers gastrointestinal cancers and cancers elsewhere in the body too so it could even be a cause of melanoma skin cancer crazy enough I'm at people with chronic H. Pylori infections that cause skin issues.
So major skin rashes and such from H. Pylori that they had no idea that H. Pylori infection.
So we treated the H. Pylori infection in their whole skin rash worldwide. So H. Pylori could be a nasty little bug that can cause a lot of problems.
Sorry off topic back to this question I've been having gas type stomach pain with somewhat of a decreased appetite the pain continues but many times this is reduced or goes away when I pass some gas sometimes the pain is pretty bad but it may last for an hour or so.
So first of all stop there all this the symptoms right here may totally not be associated with the H. Pylori just so you know taking a shot of aloe vera juice helps to alleviate the pain I also have an experience dizziness and light headiness so that may also have nothing to do with H. Pylori.
So the bacteria itself can cause ulcers too whatever I said that effect almost all stomach ulcers are caused by H. Pylori but the dizziness and light headiness is a concern to me and I'll speak on in a second this I'm thinking the dizziness of light headiness occurs on a daily basis.
And started about two weeks ago dizziness occurs when I get up from lying down or sitting for a period of time getting up from the city position just goes away with rest and time.
Okay so let's address this first before we get to the symptoms here the questions here the dizziness and light headiness when you when you stand from online or city position is a couple possibilities number one.
If the person has no underlying pathology and they said this and it's fairly might or not severe if they could adrenal fatigue your adrenal system kicks out a hormone that increases blood pressure instantaneously when you stand from a city position or stand for the lying position.
Indeed that increase in blood pressure but order to push blood to the heart or to the head when you're rising from a city or lying position so with a adrenal fatigue you could have dizziness or light headiness when upon a rising very color probably the most common cause of what is asked here.
Yeah with underlying pathology of cancer you have to rule out anemia as well so anemia which has to do with decreased blood blood cell count a decrease team of global which is the oxygen carrying capacity of the red blood cell.
We'll even if you have really healthy had radals and you have no issue with that formal production you can get the same symptoms because you have a decrease oxygen carrying capacity of oxygen to the brain so the brain functions on glucose and oxygen it's made fuel sources and when those are decreased you're going to have dizziness and light headiness.
So anemia you'd want to rule it out with a complete blood count a CBC so I don't know who wrote this question but definitely make sure you go get a CBC go get a complete blood count if you don't have a doctor who will order that call us we can order it through our site as well.
If you're out anemia if that's if you're a red blood cell count your hemoglobin is with a normal range it's definitely a adrenal fatigue and then we can deal with that with some nutrition questions are the symptoms that I'm having due to the age of pylori no and will this get better with the change of supplements that I recently had probably not know your change of supplements so you really need to rule out those two things that I just said.
Is there anything I can do differently to alleviate the pain so yes, we want to find out what that pain is coming from it if that pain is coming from possibly it also possibly the cancer we want to make sure we rule that out why did these symptoms start after I was doing and feeling pretty good well that's the nature of the beast when you're dealing with cancer as it could go in waves.
You could have months that you're feeling great then you can see the crash again and then you do well again and you might have to tweak things and that's just the way cancer is it's constantly trying to raise it's ugly headed you just need to keep beating it down so we need to get to the symptoms are signs remember so don't ignore symptoms they're signs and we want to investigate the causes to these so firstly I would say to this person we need to get some blood work done.
And see you can have the pain could be from an ulcer also and the that could cause the pain and then the ulcer of leading ulcer would cause the loss of blood in anemic state and cause the dizziness and like head in this so we want to get to the cause and figure this out.
Next questions could the black sap blood root capsules be taking that i'm taking cut off nerves in my rectal area that could make my tingling caused tingling type symptoms in that area.
I would say no because black sap blood root does does not do that even if you were putting blood root on as a paste it doesn't do that so even doing blood root that's the safe part of using blood root as a cancer killer in like a melanoma or a breast cancer that's come to the surface it doesn't kill any healthy tissue.
So it won't damage any neurons so tingling is from some sort of nerve damage from something so a cancer can cause nerve damage a chemical that is a caustic chemical can cause nerve damage like chemotherapy drugs can cause nerve damage that's why you get neuropathy.
from that so tingling is called a neuropathy so that's what you're dealing with so and I guess finished question and neuropathy works here yeah so the right let's black sap would not cause that to get worse could this cause pain where I have a moment could this be making more inflammation black sap so if the cancer is dying then you could have inflammation that's going on yes.
But black sap doesn't cause inflammation so it'd be only if the cancer is coming out or dying that you have a inflammatory response if you're if you're asking if what causes an inflammatory response an inflammatory response that is a positive inflammatory response is when your immune system is attacking something that's a good thing
and but that wouldn't be black sap that would be some other immune stimulation that you're taking so what should I do we should set up a time where we should talk and go over some ideas that we can that we can look at do I just trust the process well I think there's a time that we do trust the process but you have to be wise just like I said in the last question.
You know symptoms are signs of something your body's trying to tell you something it doesn't always be a bad thing but we at least need to investigate and walk through that you know together and and see if if we need to do anything different maybe it isn't but we need to at least ask those questions next question I noticed that a large portion of the recommended protocol this person is talking about the right what what I recommended for them.
Is a modified version of the Joe Tippen's protocol the Joe Tippen's protocol is using fed bed is all and curcumin and vitamin E and Burberry and CBD which I've never heard of it tell now so we don't typically so you're right we don't typically like oh we're put you on the Joe Tippen's protocol no we test for what we want and so we don't use
the exact protocol that somebody else created very rarely so we we may it may be similar but it's often different but seems prophesied and I expect this was I was tested for this yes so if we recommended I tested it but is it appropriate to ask what your clinical experience is with this protocol.
Sure but I can't really answer that because everybody's different and nobody's just on that though we do have people that are doing all sorts of different protocols with good and bad experience we can't cure everybody again I'm not a healer and my responsibility is just to be begging God to give me the answers and what I'm supposed to do with everybody and I pray that he that I'm listening to the Holy Spirit is best.
As I she believed possibly kale so I saw there's a Stanford case study of three humans who use the protocol interesting I've never seen that study but I've never looked for it are there others I highly doubt it.
On protocols like this like like something that is not drug related and you're just not going to find any any studies that are using that alone you can you can do a Google scholars search on curcumin to work and cancer and you can probably find 500 studies on the benefits of
to work curcumin and cancer maybe 2000 studies but most of them at least any of them that are done in the United States will be done concurrently with team therapy it's pretty hard to get an IRB that's that's what you have to do to get a study approved and that has to be approved through different processes legally and to do a human study on somebody.
Even a mouse study has to get an IRB approval you'll never get anything published without an IRB approval you will get an IRB approval with any new tricycle in the United States unless you're doing it concurrently with chemotherapy we like we did we did chemotherapy this many colon cancer patients and then we did chemotherapy with
strangle us or with curcumin or with the Joe Tippins for a call with this many cancer patients and this is the difference in these results.
Usually the number of the study is so low like three humans of this Stanford study what's not worth anything really to me.
You know in order to be a legitimate study you have to pretty good populist group but you're not going to get that unless there's some some funding behind it as well so most natural therapies you're not going to get any you're not going to find any studies some studies done in Asia.
Japan does a lot of studies on different natural therapies because they don't have the drug companies with such a poll over there so there's more altruistic effort in order to find possible cures regardless of whether there's money involved in the end.
is the United States well, pretty much.
If I could say maybe all the studies that are approved in the United States for any type of cancer therapy are funded through the pharmaceutical industry and even if they did a study and funded a study on Joe Tippins protocol.
a study of Joe Tippen's protocol. If it showed promise, they probably wouldn't publish it.
And I don't mean that just to be mean, but that's just the truth.
There's so much publication bias with studies. It would blow your socks off. They'll do a study
on a new drug, send it out to 30 different universities, pay for the studies. They'll get, if they got
29 of the university said this drug is horrible. Don't use it. But one of them said, oh, this is
prophecy. They wouldn't publish the other 29. And they'd only publish the one. How could they
be so mean? How could they be so evil? I'm sorry. If this, that's new news to you, that's
disturbing to you that it's just the, the evils of the world today. So here, it's going to be
hard press to find those studies. So it's hard to be encouraged by that. I understand. But
next question. I do a sauna approximately three times a week for 30 minutes. Today, I nearly
fainted. Could not really move. Walk when I was, when I was completed. What is the issue? Stop
going. So does completely. If that's the case, or drop it down to where you're only doing it,
maybe three times a week for five minutes. So, so, sonas are great. And the purpose of the
sonas I talked about last week, soon call, is really to get you to sweat. The purpose of the sona
is really to take some pressure off your liver and your kidneys, because your liver and your
kidneys are your main organs of detoxification that you're using on a daily basis, or you die.
So, when you, when you're sauna eating, you're sweating, then you're getting out some toxins
through your pores, or your skin, and you're using the largest organ of your body, your skin,
to help you detoxify. You could literally do the same thing by going out at a very hot day and
working in the garden and sweating like a pig. It's like taking it, doing a sauna. Very, very good for
you. Okay. Unfortunately, we can't do that in minutes, don't it this time of year. So, sonas have
to take the place of that. But if you're having adverse effects of a sauna, meaning you almost are
fatied after a sauna, you are either doing it too long, or some people actually have a version to
heat. Just the way their bodies made up, and they really shouldn't be doing any sonas at all.
Certainly, if you're having this kind of effect, you need to scale a dome to maybe maximum of five minutes.
I've had other patients that say, I can be in a sauna for 30 minutes, I'm not sweating at all.
I don't know what it is. I just don't sweat in a sauna. The more they do a sauna, and they don't
have any adverse effects, so I tell them to keep doing it. The more they do a sauna, now their
pores start opening up, and they start having the sweating effects in a shorter, shorter period,
and now they start getting benefits of being a sauna. But if you're a person that you've done 120
sonas, and you've done them for 30 minutes, and you never sweat it, well, you might as well just
stop doing a sauna, because you really miss the benefits of the sauna. That's sweating. You're not
getting a core temperature increase in a sauna enough to really affect any deep cancers.
If you have a skin cancer, a sauna can be very good. If you have a brain cancer, you really
shouldn't be doing a sauna for a brain cancer. For a child, you really shouldn't be doing a sauna
with a child. Shouldn't be doing a sauna. I know different people will say differently.
That's just my opinion. I don't think that's wise. Okay, so your questions on the chat. My son
has encouraged NAD, IV treatments, and hyperbaric oxygen chamber,
not marked pro-orcona. My recommendations, are there any general contour indications?
Yes, you want to do some research on the NAD IV treatments for sure. There can be some
very strict contour indications, and you can get some severe adverse reactions on that. That's not
my specialty by any stretch of the imagination, but I've had patients in NAD IVs were very big for
people that had drug addictions. They were very beneficial for that, but they also pushed out a lot
of toxins that caused a lot of severe adverse reactions, and they were actually outlawed in the
United States. I know for a period of time. I would check into that. I wouldn't just jump into that.
Hyperbaric oxygen chamber really is good for anybody, as long as you can tolerate it. Some people
like with my sinus issues, I can't do it, and some people have issues with just claustrophobia.
But hyperbaric oxygen is a great tool for brain cancer, but it's a great tool for anything. It's
really good for your brain. It's really good for helping to ward off early dementia as well. So
it's a great, and it can be helpful for other cancers. But most of the studies, the hyperbaric
and cancer have to do with brain cancer. So I would look at the contour indications that I've not
want to speak about with NAD. I would really investigate that before I jump into that.
Sometimes I get splits in the skin in my thumb and pointer finger and big toe
that I think have been associated with the right accessories like the spiral ball is this common.
I could not, for the life of me, think that the right had anything to do with splits in the skin.
Typically when you have a split in the skin like that, it's a nutritional deficiency.
We should think about doing a blood test for nutrients. I can't think off the top by hand what the
nutritional deficiencies are when you get split skins like that. I don't have to look it up. But there
is blood tests for or that measures nutrients in red blood cells. That's a good one to run
that I could look up as well. So contact your liaison about that.
Question, what is blue methylene and what is it used for?
I don't know. I don't know. Next question. I missed a few first few minutes of today's call.
So if you mentioned this, I apologize. Have you sent the email? Yes. So we're sending the email
out at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning central standard time. So look in your junk spam folder because it may
go to spam because it's going out to everybody all at once. So when an email goes out to a lot of
people many times, your Gmail or something will push it to spam or to promotions. So make sure you
look at that. It's going out at 10 o'clock central time tomorrow morning. So if you don't get the email,
then email me at info at cuttersclinic.com. I at at at cuttersclinic.com say I didn't get the email.
And I will make sure your email is in the system to do that. So some people may not get the email
because for some reason, we don't have them in our email system for that.
Can imagine that we don't, but some people might not.
Okay, next question. I was looking forward to catching smoking, eating some catfish this season.
Why is catfish on my cancer protocol a no eat list would rather would other fish with scales
that are bottom feeders be on the no eat list to like suckers from clean water. By the way,
I am a new subscriber. Just began the protocol this week.
Yeah, so it's catfish are on the no eat list mainly because they're bottom feeders.
Just like shrimp and lobster and things like that. So can you eat them once in a while?
Yes. Okay, so yes. Better fact, I might come over to your house when you're going to have this meal
because it sounds really good. But that's another story. So again, with your diet that we're giving you,
it is not a religion. It is something for you to follow as best you can. So we put no
pork on somebody's thing. Does it mean you can't have a little bit of ham on Easter dinner
when everybody else is eating it? No, you can. So just it's not something like if you ate just a
little, your cancer is going to take off roe or anything. That's not the issue. And with catfish,
that's not the issue at all. It's not a feeder of the cancer. It's just a good for you because
they're bottom feeders and a feeding bottom feeders. You're just getting, you know,
not the best food quality. But, you know, there's lots of things that we all do that aren't the best
food quality. So it's heavy. It's just understanding that balance. It's understanding that this is not
a religion. This is just some, the best protocols, the best recommendations for you and the testing.
So just do it as best you can. I don't want anybody to be so anal about their protocol, their
nutritional protocol, their dietary protocol, that it is that they're concerned about it. They
have an anxiety about it. You will miss the mark then if that's the case. We're trying to get the
best idea of what to do to move forward to give you the best outcome, not cause more anxiety. So
make sure of that. So hope that answers the question, Jim. Any other questions?
You do want to speak a question and you can just unmute yourself, but I cannot unmute you. So
I have a lot of people on the call today. Okay, I've got a few words on my hands in the last few
months. I haven't had any words since I was a teen. These grow, grew for a few months and then turned
black and died. Do you think this is a detox symptom or a virus fighting to survive? Wow. Good insight
there. Could be either one of those, but words tend to grow also when you're deficient in zinc. So
keep that in mind. I've had kids with words said and as patients and just putting them on some zinc
can actually make the words fall off. So with cancer, it's not uncommon to have your zinc levels
decrease. So just take it a little zinc can help too. But it looks like, at least in this question,
that it was solved with your body dealt with it. The words are a virus, yes, and it could be the virus
just trying to survive and stay alive. Yes, it could be your body just detoxing this virus too, yes.
But if you do have persistent words, make sure you take zinc. And I always tell people with
words to take zinc, if you're an adult, about 50 milligrams a day for a week, on a week off a week,
on a week off a week. This is a person what I used to have patients and we're not in cancer patients.
And pretty much most people with words fell off with kids you don't do as high a dose of milligrams,
but the same procedure on a week off a week off a week can usually by the third week or fourth week
the words literally fall off. Quay, is the test you're talking about in the question about the
split skin of the Cyrex test? No. No, that's not what the test is. You could do a Cyrex test,
and it's possibly, it's possible that a food sensitivity could cause that if you're talking about the
Cyrex 10. But I have to look that up. I'll try to bring this question back up next week
or make a short video about it. But there's some other deficiency with split skin, so I'll look
that up. Next question, in order to stimulate the parasympathetic nerve, I have started using
parasympathetic essential oil. It seems to be working. Is this okay? I don't know what
parasympathetic essential oil you're talking about. Perhaps you could share that.
But essential oils can be beneficial. I don't know where you're putting this essential oil also.
So, your parasympathetic nervous system, remember, is mainly controlled by radial nerve 10.
And that's the side of the autonomic nervous system that causes detoxification, that helps with
elimination, that causes relaxation, and stimulates your immune response. So that's of course what we
want to stimulate. And that's the main purpose why a person would do coffee enemas is to stimulate
the vagal nerve, creatinine nerve 10, stimulating the parasympathetics. Biberate blue oil makes
a sympathetic oil. Oh, it's a mix of blend. Okay. I'm not sure who came up with the idea that a
specific blend. Okay, it's lime and clove. Interesting. I've never heard that so great. Are you
placing it any place specific? So the reason why you do coffee enemas is because you have exposure
the vagal nerve in the rectum and you're stimulating that vagal nerve there.
There's a whole list, remember, if you go back to this, and you search parasympathetic right there,
I have a video on understanding sympathetic versus parasympathetic, and I have two
downloadable PDFs on how to stimulate your parasympathetics and to calm your sympathetic.
So you're putting it behind your ear on your mastoid bone. Interesting. Actually, you have another spot
on your ear, but it's on your lobe on the inside of your lobe to show you where it is that is actually
another spot where you can stimulate your parasympathetics. There was a company out in Europe a few
years ago that made like a little tens unit type thing that had a specific clip that you could clip
on that spot, and then you turn that on because there are people that have very serious disorders
where their sympathetic are literally out of control, and they need constant parasympathetic
stimulation. Those are the anxiety disorders that are readily using medication, which
doesn't necessarily work that well. So you might think about putting it on your lobe, but it's on the
inside of your crest, on your lobe. I have to pull up a picture and I'll try to remember to share that
next picture. But anything you can do to stimulate your parasympathetics, that's why it's very
beneficial to just go take a walk in the woods or to your happy place because you're basically
stimulating your parasympathetics. Anything you do to calm stress down is a stimulation of parasympathetics
because anything you can do to calm your sympathetic. It's kind of like a teetretotter
if you're hypersympathetic, you're going to be hypoperasympathetic. So anything you do to
calm the sympathetic, or to fight a flight response down, the better off you're going to be
of the more healing you're going to have. That's why I say, over and over again, the more stressed you
are, the anxiety you're in and you are focused you are on your cancer, the more you're feeling your
cancer. So you have to calm down, and nobody's ever calmed down by telling them to calm down,
I get it, but you have to figure out how you can achieve that in your life. So please go
to the website search parasympathetic or sympathetic, and you'll see a video about your exercises that
will help you achieve that as best as possible. So I have access to a P-E-M-F at my dog's vet.
Yeah, do you realize that P-E-M-F is used by more veterinarians than health care practitioners for
humans? Since he's not a human cancer doctor, I would like some instruction on how to use the
machine. Can you give me some direction? Do I put the P-E-M-F directly on the cancer site?
So it depends on what kind of machine he has. It depends if it's a low-gouse or high-gouse machine,
so we need some information on that. But even if it's a high-gouse machine,
it's a pulse that you feel and you hear this ding, ding, ding, ding, and you feel a pulse like an
electric stim going through you. You really can't hurt yourself by putting it right out of the
cancer. You would not ever put it over your head, or you can, you said sure that we're really low.
But yeah, the only thing you have to watch with P-E-M-F, you cannot use it if you have an
electrically implanted device, so if you have a defibrillator or a pacemaker, you don't want to be
using the P-E-M-F. It's an electrical device. But if you don't have electrical device, it's pretty
hard to hurt yourself with P-E-M-F if you have a machine that you could turn it up if you turn it up
to a tolerable pulse. If what he has is a low-gouse P-E-M-F, meaning that you turn it up all the way,
you still don't feel it, then it's literally impossible to hurt yourself with it. So
you could use it anywhere. He might have one with panels. He might have one with pads. I don't
know. So there's a lot of different apparatuses that go along with the P-E-M-F device that you could use.
Sounds like if you have the ability to put it over something, then he has a one with panels. If
yes, you could put it over the cancer, you could put it over your liver, you could just do general
P-E-M-F over your body so that you just get a good boost and energy that could be beneficial.
How should I rate the importance of my specific diet, which makes perfect sense to me,
and the recommendation to follow a low histamine diet which seems contrary and difficult
to make sense of it in itself? I would agree. A low histamine diet is difficult. We seem to have
this question just about every Zoom call and I have to remind everybody that it is simply that
you're lowering your histamine level. So histamine is an inflammatory cytokine that's made
by immune cells to trigger an immune response to an area and histamine is in a lot of foods.
When you eat foods with histamine in it, you're basically causing inflammation. You've got
now normally if you eat foods with histamine in it, you have a gene in the cells of your gut that
will make an enzyme called DAO that will break down the histamine in the food and you don't usually have
much of a problem with that. You have defects on that gene and you don't make DAO enzyme very well
then you can have a problem with that because that can be at least a piece of a cause of people with
gut problems. So even people without cancer, they can have gut problems and chronic gut issues,
chronic food sensitivities, having a lot of food sensitivities, can seem to get over it,
digestive issues, and it can be at least partly caused by histamine issues because of the effects of
the DAO gene. That being said, when you make the DEO enzyme in the gut, you don't really absorb
that very well, it just works out the histamine to the gut. High histamines in the gut, you can absorb
histamines and it can increase histamines or overall inflammation in your body. That's not really
a good inflammation so it's an overall chronic inflammation. So decreasing histamines in your diet
is one solution, it's not really a solution, but it helps. So I think of histamine as a bucket
and it fills this bucket or histamines fill a bucket and then you can have problems with that bucket
as full. So if you could disc decrease some histamine foods, it can just be helpful. So that's the
idea of a low histamine diet, we just don't wear of it. Okay, so I might have a little bit of a
histamine issue, so I'm not going to eat a bowl full of nuts or I'm not going to eat a bowl full of
strawberries. So I mean, I won't eat strawberries with my salad. No, because I mean, I won't have
few nuts with my trail mix or my salad. No, you can still have some nuts, so if you mix it with
other foods, you're not going to have this spike of histamine. So that's the idea with a low histamine
diet, you're just doing your best. So don't get crazy anal about that. Just do your best.
Is taking flax oil with high lignin good for breast cancer.
You are positive. Usually yes, actually, lignins can be good for cancer, especially breast cancer.
So it can be good, yeah. There seems to be several thoughts on this matter.
We don't use flax oil. I typically don't test for it, to be honest, because of some
negatives with it. But if you feel like your being led to do that, and you're having good results,
then I would say you should stop. But what's the difference between the DAO gene and the ABP1 gene as far
as histamines? So the DAO gene is the DAO gene makes histamine in the gut. The ABP1 gene and the HNMT
gene make histamine or make the enzyme to break down histamine in the gut. The ABP1 gene and the HNMT gene
make the DAO enzyme that breaks out histamine in the tissue. So if I have a lot of ABP1 and HNMT gene
defects, I don't break down histamine in my tissue as good as I possibly could. That doesn't necessarily
mean I'm going to have more histamine in my tissue, but it does mean that that possibility exists.
So then using something like histamine scavenger product to help break down histamine in overall
inflammation in my tissue is the right thing. If I have a lot of defects in my DAO genes,
then I might have more issues with my gut. Usually people with a lot of DAO gene defects
tend to have more issues, more gut issues. People with ABP1 and HNMT gene defects tend to have more
issues in the tissues, meaning like seasonal allergy type issues. They scratch your skin and you
have all these scratch marks on your skin because of the red. It looks like you just rub against
barboil or something. I just itched my arm. That's where that's the histamine that can really
cause more cancer issues because it's in the tissues. So it is different where it's located
and it's different where the enzyme is being created. Is it being created in the gut?
Where I said the DAO enzyme that is being created in the gut to break down histamines in the gut
typically does not absorb. So histamines absorb and if you have defects in DAO enzymes in your E,
a ton of histamines, foods, you could be absorbing some of those and that could cause more
tissue issues too. So but it is that it's where the enzyme is being created. So where it's breaking
down the histamine for the tissues or the gut? What are the other questions? So will we know that
difference? Will we know or tested it with? Yes, we'll know that by the genetic test. So the genetic
test is going to show either DAO gene defects or ABP1 gene defects or HNTG defects or I mean everybody
has some defects but it's when you have it abnormally high about the defects that it's a concern.
Okay, so everybody I'm really looking forward to the launch of our member site understand it's a work
in progress. So when you get that email at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning central time I'll make sure
you log in and you'll see it's got a number of pages. It's like a whole website. Okay, so
it's got things out there that are not on our website and it will obviously have all the zoom calls
out there and it will have other short videos of frequently asked questions out there and I'll just
continue to make more things to go out there. We just want to continue to improve that site
for you guys. So if you have you know ideas to improve it and for sure share those too
um doesn't mean I'll do it but I'm just kidding. So if you have ideas to improve it, we'll do our best to
make it the best site possible for you guys. So can heavy metal detox put back pull too too much
iron to cause anemia. No, it's not going to pull out too much iron to cause anemia. It's really not
going to pull out unless you're doing it like 10 times a day you're really not going to end up with
pulling out too many minerals either but again we recommend maximum of once a day
doing that really a couple times a week would be good. You don't need to really go beyond that.
Shouldn't really be doing it more than once a day unless there's
that's real issue specifically for you. It definitely won't pull out enough iron to cause anemia.
What's the best way to track and find sources of inflammation?
Good question. I mean you can find if a person is inflamed through different blood tests
but sources of inflammation then you go into it's called differential diagnosis and you kind of
got to do some investigative research on your body. So what are the most common sources of inflammation?
So you dig into foodborne allergens and that's where I do that Syrex 10 test can be beneficial
because you can be doing a lot of things good to decrease inflammation but then if you're
let's say eating a food let's use glutinous an example that gluten is not a driver of my cancer
but if I have antibodies to gliadin or any of the gliadin peptides and I mean gluten I'm causing
this constant ramped up inflammation in my gut in my brain in my body that I'm fighting against
constantly and if I just dealt with that the food group whether it be gluten or something else
that is that I have antibodies against the stop eating that was my inflammation would drop
considerably so doing a Syrex 10 test can be very wise to do you can find these hidden things
of inflammation so most common things of inflammation probably food is going to be a major one
second is environmental exposure to things mold is a huge one
toxins pesticides herbicides these are all poisons that your body if you absorb them can
react to in an inflammatory state trying to protect your body because your body sees the old adage
delusion is the solution to pollution it's very true you you become inflamed causing increase in
fluid production to help dilute the toxin that you're dealing with so very wise to look into those
things if you have inflammation I'd say food in the environmental toxins are your most common
things I had a health care practitioner tell me that a pH of 8 is desirable using alkaline water
is this true well if we want to get into the whole pH discussion again
certainly can but just let's just think about this a little bit
your stomach has a pH above 2.5 that's very acidic pH is your
is a measurement of acidity and alkalinity the middle of 7.0 your blood has a pH about 7.34
it doesn't very much from that or you'll die your body has a buffering system in order to buffer
your blood polls calcium out of the tissues of the bones in order to buffer the blood
it also does that in order to make hydrochloric acid in the stomach so your body creates hydrochloric
acid and your stomach is very acidic and it's the only place in your body that's very acidic
there's no place in your body that's very alkaline understand too high alkalinity is just as
caustic is too low of a pH too high of acidity it's just as dangerous and just as caustic
in in an organic chemistry laboratory you have to be careful with just as careful with the
acids as you have to be careful with the bases that can be just as caustic to your body
so drinking water at a high pH to me makes just no sense whatsoever you're putting something at a
high pH into your stomach that's at a pH of 2.5 it's not going into your small intestine at a pH of 8
so you're not absorbing a water at a pH of 8 because you're drinking a water at a pH of 8
we just understand just cursory physiology you should I just don't understand the thought process
of that you can see good nutrition books that say you should be drinking lemon water because it's
alkalizing to you well lemon water if you stick a pH strip of that is going to have a pH that's acidic
because lemon juice is acidic why is that alkalizing it's not alkalizing or acidifying because of
the pH of the substance it's alkalizing or acidifying to your body because of the helpfulness of the
product so lemon water is alkalizing to your body body even though it's acidic because lemon is good
for you so it has nothing to do with the pH of the water that you're drinking it has to do
whether it's good for you so one would better argue that drinking more water will help your body
has nothing to do whether the water is acidic or alkaline so don't go by a pH machine to
alkalize your water you already have one fight but it's it's not helping anybody um secondly it could
actually hurt you because I mean that really I mean your your your stomach production of HCl will
probably be strong enough to handle you drinking a pH of 8 water but you are literally watering
down the pH the acid in your stomach necessary for you to digest foods so you have an acidity of
your stomach of 2.5 for a purpose it's a physiological purpose in order for you to break down
carbohydrates and proteins in a little bit of the fat that's the purpose of that so if you have
an elevated pH in your stomach let's say it's not at 2.5 it's 5.0 because your body isn't making
enough hydrochloric acid you're going to cause ill health that is one of the major reasons why you
have h pylori overgrowth of the stomach and causes of of ulcers and what we discussed earlier in
this talk about with h pylori causing stomach cancer it's because h pylori is ubiquitous everywhere
in your body it's a bacteria that is an opportunistic organism you know take off if your pH of your
stomach is elevated meaning you're less acidic so actually you could be causing yourself
h pylori infection by drinking high alkaline water but we could argue that tell the cows come home
but that's just my physiological answer that makes the most sense to me so I just don't understand why
anybody would take that way but I could be completely wrong so I open to discussion
and I was using organic lemon juice in a smoothie every morning for years but the low
histoby diet we are told to stay away from citrus yikes yeah again again it's that balance okay
doesn't mean you can't have some lemon juice in your smoothie every morning that's not going to spike
your histamine levels plus again when you have something with histamine mixed with other things it's
it's kind of watery down the histamine so it's not going to be a big issue remember
and almost everything has histamine so it's not about eliminated histamines it's about you know
I'm not going to not eat strawberries because they have histamines in it but you know
it's certainly not going to not eat nuts I'm going to say it's my favorite food so
but maybe I'll eat it a little less maybe I'll make some with other things maybe I'll just be aware
of that conscious of that if I eat it with an empty stomach that's probably not quite as good
I might get a spike in histamines I might be over task taxing my system I might be filling my
histamine bucket too quickly so you just conscious about this you're not becoming able about
any of these things you're just like okay well maybe I still like lemon in my smoothie I think
I'll still do that but maybe I'll cut this back a little bit so it's just having that balanced
approach where you're not getting too crazy about it because what does that do again that stimulates
your sympathetic and now you're in this anxious state and you've just counteracted everything that you've
done to try to stimulate your parasympathetics so just keep that in mind when we when we write these
protocols for you they're just do your best approach all right we're at an hour so I'm going to
bid a do thank you guys for all your prayers for us ask that you just keep them up and remember
at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning central time we'll be sending this out and if you don't get an email
just email me and we'll try to get you going on the list I won't be that it works if it doesn't work
I get to apologize in advance we've been working on this for five months now try to get this
membership cycle and so just try to give you extra stuff all the time everywhere we can so all right
God bless everybody and we will talk next week